I'm Jason Chaffetz in for Laura Ingram
and this is a special edition of the
Inger mangle from New York City
last month the angle reported on a
Twitter files dump from our next guest
Michael schellenberger in it he exposed
the Deep connection between the Federal
Bureau of Investigation and Twitter
including how adamant James Baker then
general counsel for the social media
giant was about the hunter Biden story
being in violation of Twitter policies
but there's one section that didn't
receive as much attention as the rest it
included details about how media
organizations and big Tech including
former employees of the Department of
Justice agreed to working in concert to
protect Joe Biden against damaging
stories this all happened at the Aspen
Institute in August of 2020 labeled a
tabletop exercise on combating
disinformation it quickly morphed into
smothering a perfectly legitimate story
now due to new emails given to us by
schellenberger we know the effort was
organized by Vivian Schiller former NPR
president and former Twitter Global
chair of news and once we started
pulling the threat of which journalists
and social media employees were involved
we found other past associations that
should raise eyebrows
first is Nathaniel glyker current head
of cyber security policy at Facebook
formerly of the Department of Justice
and these two Andrew Grotto and Janine
Zakaria both from Stanford and the
latter a former bureau chief at the
Washington Post now Stanford's
connection is important because it was
their playbook that this Harem of
journalists would operate from the
University's cyber Center published a
10-point quote Newsroom playbook for
propaganda reporting
the irony being that their guidelines
would result in said propaganda the most
interesting of these steps is number 10.
which says networks must hire reporters
assigned to cover the disinformation or
a propaganda b as viewers of this
channel know full well these quote
unquote media disinformation reporters
have become the foremost purveyors of
slanderous propaganda themselves
the hunter Biden laptop Apparently that
is still very much under active
investigation of whether it's part of a
foreign disinformation plot the U.S
authorities are seeing if those emails
we just talked about are connected to an
ongoing Russian disinformation effort it
is so obviously a Russian operation they
are saying this as you know this is no
basis in reality a bunch of intelligence
officials uh point to this big Russian
disinformation
all reading from the same Playbook again
these are supposed competitors agreeing
that getting Joe Biden elected was more
important than their stated Mission as
journalists or operators of a social
media platform hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else